We might've asked rhetorically on whose
taxes the president,
President Obama wants to increase the
standard journalistic responses.
The rich,
my preferred response is Republicans.
Republican voters are disproportionately
wealthy,
uh,
and he wants to tax Republicans to
reward Democrats they want to cut
spending in order to reduce the deficit.
And where would they like to reduce
spending entitlements?
Who disproportionately benefits from
entitlements the relatively poor who
disproportionately vote Democrat.
The Republicans want to punish the
Democrats to reward their constituents.
The Democrats want to punish the
Republicans to reward.
There's,
how might we fix this?
Well,
it would be nice,
for example,
if a,
we,
the people elected the congress instead
of the members of Congress choosing who
their voters will be.
Gerrymandering ensures that the congress
gets to pick its voters around the other
way around.
So the probability of being reelected as
an incumbent in the congress is 95
percent,
almost as high as it was in the old
Soviet Union of being reelected to their
parliament.
Uh,
we've got a rig system.
We could fix that.
Or there are lots of excellent political
science studies on how to design a
redistricting.
So that it's completely nonpartisan.
It's entirely one person,
one vote,
a subject to geographic constraints and
topology.
We could write computer programs that do
redistricting.
Now,
no member of Congress is going to agree
to that in the short term because that
would put her or his hold on power at
risk.
But if we were to pass a law that says
starting in 20 years or 25 years,
this program will be used to do
redistricting.
We would have solved the problem of the
voters not choosing their members of
Congress.
And that will go a long way to altering
the risk of being thrown out of office
if you don't do what the,
what the people want.
And we'd get much better policy.
But that's very far down the road.
Shorter term.
Also hard to do a,
we could get rid of the electoral
college.
It's,
it's useful to remember that,
uh,
you know,
when people speak about standing by the
original constitution and so forth,
being strict constitutionalist,
the electoral college was designed as a
slavery institution.
We got rid of slavery.
We haven't gotten rid of this slavery
institution.
We ought to,
that too would ensure,
uh,
that,
presidents would be more responsive to a
still larger coalition and that would
mean doing more of what we,
the people want.